et was with bachelor Chris soules and
his new fiancee Whitney Bischoff just
hours after the couple's first public
appearance and they meant it to us
they're not rushing to say I did we
haven't said one thing they do have
confirmed is that their pal Jimmy Kimmel
will be there and possibly even
officiating the ceremony he will yes he
may be like he made a couple couldn't
look any happier but are they concerned
about the franchise's breakup curse I
think that it's important to not focus
on on that and to focus on that's as a
couple we both are really excited about
where we're headed I think for me it's
just important to you know stay focused
on that and kind of block all of that
outside noise we didn't go on the show
for anything but finding someone and and
that's our number one focused the
history of the bachelor is not really a
concern to either of us and I wouldn't
have gone on if I didn't know if I would
have looked at the past they're delaying
their plans to live on Chris's farm in
Arlington to live in LA where Chris will
be competing on Dancing with the Stars
you can see his moves when season 20
premieres Monday March 16